أجنبي ،
أعتقد أن هناك مخاوف حول
أه ما سيحدث لسوق العمل
حيث أننا مع إجازة نهائية
ونقترب من نهاية العام ،
فأنا قلق ، أعني
أنه يبدو أن
هناك الكثير من الأشياء المغرية في الخارج
لذا فهي كذلك  أشعر أنه قد يكون هناك بعض
العمل ، ولكن فقط فيما يتعلق بالمستقبل على المدى الطويل ،
فأنا قلق بشأن
ما سأفعله ، لقد كان من الصعب عليهم
العثور على وظائف أخرى ستدفع لهم ما يكفي من
أجل أن يكونوا قادرين على العيش و
لقد ساعد مخطط الإجازة
ولكنه لم يذهب بعيدًا
عن ضغوط معرفة ما إذا كانت ستكون هناك
وظائف متاحة أم لا ، فقد كان
دائمًا مصدر القلق الرئيسي ،
نعم إنه لأمر محزن أننا نعلم أن لدينا
12 متجرًا في عام 2018
وحوالي 50 موظفًا لذلك لدينا اليوم مثل
نحن نقف ثلاثة متاجر
أجنبية